[Theremin sounds]
My name is Dorit Chrysler.
I'm a musicologist and composer. I also play the theremin.
I helped co-found the New York Theremin Society
and also started a program, Kidcoolthereminschool
to teach Theremin internationally
and I'm delighted to
talk about the Theremin here today at
Harvard. Lots of different possibilities
How does the Theremin work?
It is completely different than all the
traditional music interfaces we are
familiar with and they also developed
over thousands of years, where the Theremin
in comparison is a very young instrument.
It basically creates two electromagnetic
fields one horizontal and one vertical
This is the pitch antenna, so...
...the closer I go to the pitch antenna, the higher the
pitch and this is the volume. Here it is...
...the further away my hand is, the louder it gets.
So I'm sculpting each bland sinus note
with the volume
[Music]
while trying to find the pitch, which is
constant intonation. It's kind of like a
bumblebee buzzing around the flower
which is a pitch and you're trying to
land on it.
[Music]